parece que fue fundamental hablar de la
unión porque los eeuu el anterior
presidente
camps sabemos que
mantuvo un discurso de división en los
eeuu y esto la verdad eso cabo una serie
d
estamentos que ya los norteamericanos
tenían dentro de su democracia un
ejemplo de ello porque se está esta
petición que hace vaivén al derecho del
voto como recordarán en las últimas
elecciones que fueron de las elecciones
más votadas en los eeuu hubo una serie
de incidentes en diferentes estados de
la unión de los eeuu desde esta nación y
propició que diferente que estos estados
impulsarán algunas leyes que de alguna
manera entorpece digamos el proceso
electoral entonces este llamado está
este llamado a la unión del presidente
de bailén y esta es la exigencia de que
se se haga que se revise este derecho al
voto es muy muy importante y además de
cara a una en un contexto donde hay una
guerra en donde hay
la unión es parte de este discurso en
donde
se está uniendo el mundo en contra de
rusia me parece que es una es un disco
que es un concepto el concepto de unión
lo está usando en ambos en ambos
estadios eso es así que me parece que el
hablar de unión en estos momentos para
bailén fue muy importante la gente está
muy dividida y ahora con el tema de
además de la difícil situación económica
me parece que les pone una mayor una
mayor dificultad
en lograr la unidad en los
norteamericanos